ich war mit meinen freunden skifahren
und beim skifahren ist neben dem
skifahren eine sache besonders wichtig
und das ist das essen auf den hütten
weil jeder der maschinen war weiß es ist
einfach das besonderes und nach so einem
anstrengenden skitag auf eine hütte zu
fahren nirgendwo schmeckt es so gut
deshalb habe ich mir zur aufgabe gemacht
ein passierten zu testen wir waren
nämlich im skigebiet dass der dave sehr
gut kennt er hat mir tipps gegeben ich
habe von euch tipps bekommen und das ist
das video dazu viel spaß damit wir
beginnen bei der ersten hütte die keine
ganz normale hütte ist
ab und packt das ganze in einen kleinen
block deshalb viel spaß arbeit wir
werden so festlich weisen heute nicht
dabei sind übrigens safe und ganz viele
andere mal wieder irgendwelche werden
aktionen auf der piste und es wird ein
wahrer traum
[Musik]
wie sie jetzt gleich beim ersten stopp
der hüttentour direkt bei der luxus
adressen wenn ich mal der kristallhütte
wo du mir mal oft empfohlen und jetzt
sage dass ich die chance geben und
[Musik]
klavier begleitet mich hier vorne ist
das geht es erstmal so eine rezeption
also erst eindruck das ist auf jeden
fall ernst eine kassette also mit
einlass mit heizstrahlern nach heftigen
aussicht und wahrscheinlich auch mit ein
bisschen höheren teil wird was untypisch
ist klappt das schon einmal gegeben in
der hippen food wirkt die teilen uns
jetzt nur eine mahlzeit weil ich muss
mir essen in diesem video waren gleich
zur nächsten seite
hast du schon mal statt so karte gesehen
wichtig
ist alle drittel pommes 11 90 ich sag
mal was raus sehr geil plastic vom
heimischen stier oder gummi im schnitt
vier gänge menü 54 euro ok also sind
kleine spiele und die triple kommen ist
einfach weil das passte gut hierher
nehmen wir das
hat nicht gereicht betrifft kommen aber
es ist wirklich sehr sehr kraft ich
zeige euch das panorama gleich noch mal
haben wir sitzen hier inmitten von den
bergspitzen und so ganz krass für die
musik ist nicht zuletzt ein drink und
was feines zu essen
es ist schon ist schon geil aber es ist
halt für mich persönlich schon etwas
untypisch für so eine hütte wenn das so
einfach ist
[Musik]
also postma dem projekt zunächst einmal
ein bisschen ta ta ta ta auf malta sieht
aber sehr gut aus
das super lecker man merkt auf jeden
fall das ist super fröschen hat
irgendwie trotzdem auf sowas kerniges
unterdessen zeit superfeinen aber fast
trotzdem so ein bergpanorama dieser
busch dabei ist auch noch verwenden
busch in der tat muss auch die marken zu
probieren ist also diesen super hübsch
aus ist richtig den rieden will dabei
das ihrem klassiker soll hütten klassik
schönwald
da ist der kann man kann man wirklich
sehr abfeiern fühlt sich ein bisschen
wie im ostkreis in köln erinnert euch
das lieblingsrestaurant auf und jobs
sind ein heizstrahler im bad fans die es
über nacht heizstrahler über kopf
absolute empfehlung welches angebot der
käse wird so richtig schmecken super
frisch und sehr weiß wo man merkt dass
selbst gemacht und obendrauf so frischen
müsse ja erst ab 50 euro für so einen
kleinen snack schon ganz ordentlich mit
4 2 aber das ist die sache auch seine
art und weise schon wer freue mich aber
auch auf den übrigen würden sie jetzt
besuchen das gibt sagt nächster stopp
kaltenbacher hier sieht sich ja schon
von mir sieht richtig schön gut aus und
das ist dells lieblings wirtschaft
besser werde ich wahrscheinlich auch
einfach das bestellen was dave erstellt
das coole ist die liegt an einem lift
der aktuell gesperrt dass das heißt wir
werden später mit dem skidoo
hochgefahren also richtig die sind ja im
zillertal in daves heimat skigebiet und
dave häufig so sehr auf die hütte ich
habe
richtig richtig ehrlicher skihütte wir
fahren ja seit jahren seit 20 jahren mit
der familie kennen die leute die hier
arbeiten das ist billig schiebetür nicht
zu keinen das essen schmeckt aber super
es richtig geil was ist deine bestellung
wenn man auf ruppiges essen später dass
die currywurst der absolut way to go
aber der kaiserschmarren hier ist auch
riesengroß und richtig gut also
vielleicht sogar beides wir brauchen
beides
[Musik]
da steht es vor mir das prachtstück was
ich noch druck oder my fire heißt in der
karosse noch mario drin und zwiebel
alter ich fühle was für meinen stil der
so genannte apps eher lustig ja es wird
nichts helfen auszuprobieren ob diese
eine gabel wird immer alles
entscheidende werde ich es genau so sehr
lieben die suche
aber es ist also ob diese kombination
ist eigentlich schon sowas holländisches
eine so kuriose zwiebeln drin bei uns
richtig verwerten und die pommes es ist
hab ich genau was du gesagt hast noch so
anstrengen kann braucht schon genau das
hier richtig
traf man aus und rief
das ist
meiner ist kaiserschmarren häufigsten
von guten gegessen er sieht schon sehr
sehr gut aus so richtig großes stückchen
direkt apfelmus waren
so richtig platine jetzt ernst ganz
wichtig das ist und außen ist eine
karamellisiertem zucker kurze der super
flüssig würde nur selbst nicht schaffen
deshalb übergebe ich ihn gerne weiter
also es ist der absolute traum bleibt
noch ein schnaps mit der moni getrunken
falls dieses video sie niemals erreichen
sollte du bist eine absolute ehre frau
und mein favorit bisher würde sagen
[Musik]
wir haben noch feinste diesen gekostet
und dave de ist wahrlich voll
super
[Musik]
zweiter tag heute steht das ganz
besonders auf dem plan nämlich eine
schnitzerei oder schnitzel in moskau und
brüssel plätze der welt gehen soll das
klingt sehr gut aussehen
[Musik]
wir sind übrigens hier die ganze zeit
mit dem bus von kava kava unterwegs
waren für uns freundlicherweise für
unseren trip zur verfügung gestellt
bigstock die haben damals schon im ihr
angebot nämlich zu unterstützen hat sich
fritz weineck gekauft habe und jetzt
immer zusammen gekommen ich kann mir
also ich kann ehrlich nur sagen aber
übels geil wir sind alle gemeinsam hier
in wiso eine große reisegruppe in diesem
bus gegen gefahren das hat den urlaub
direkt auf auf der hinfahrt rich gut
staatenloser bundesdeutsche spiel egal
ist sondern irgendwo anders und bietet
sechs unabhängigen irgendwo in fahrt
wenn gruppe wie lang und ich brauche
jetzt ein riesenschritt sind nur liebe
zur nächste adresse schnitzel hätte ich
bin sehr gespannt da waren wir also die
schnitzel dave hat gesagt als große
stütze ich dachte mir das ist ein großes
schnitze aber dann wusste ich was ein
großes schnitt ist alter die haben
komplett übertrieben ich hab noch nie
irgendwo so etwas gesehen das war so
meine hand mal szenen gefühl dave hat
auch die ganze zeit gesagt das sind 20
schnitzelbrötchen das schnitzel und es
stimmt auch wieder bildhübsches panorama
und für die größe auch wirklich faire
preise ich meine dieses gigantische
schnitzel für 18 euro 90 und jetzt kann
man sich vielleicht fragen schmeckt das
überhaupt aber das ist eine der sachen
die mir wirklich in erinnerung geblieben
ist diese schnitzel in der größe hat bei
jedem bisschen übel style geschmückt es
war wirklich so knusprig es war denn es
war saftig und es ist einfach lustig so
was mal zu essen ich meine er das öfter
als zweimal macht ich habe glaube ich
auch nach dem spiel oder ob fünf kilo
mehr geborgen aber vollkommen der
empfehlung was soll ich sagen es hat
mich wirklich ausgeloggt schnitzel ich
habe danach den nächsten drei tage im
urlaub nur noch geschlafen dann spaß ich
meinen urlaub machen deshalb habe ich
nicht so wahnsinnig viel gefilmt aber es
hat trotzdem spaß gemacht diese kleine
hütten erfahrungen mit euch zu teilen
wir waren auch gar nicht bei anderen
hütten und jan richter beide
kaltenbacher ich habe auch noch mal gern
gegessen und was aber es war alles super
lecker aber ich hoffe es hat euch spaß
gemacht das ganze kann man mit
sicherheit auch nochmal im xxl-format
machen wenn dann der eric sich auch mal
mit den urlaub bequem aber wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal wieder ich habe es hat
spaß gemacht bis dahin und ich gehe es
von diesem riesenschnitzel träumen
h